hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain a Chinese romance drama film
called better days spoilers ahead watch
out and take care
[Music]
the movie opens up in a classroom where
a young teacher Chen neon is teaching
the importance of English everyone seems
to be paying attention except for one
girl who looks upset Chen notices her
and suddenly recalls something from her
past following this the movie goes into
a flashback where Chen is still in high
school she is an intelligent student who
always tops her class since the exams
are coming Chen usually wears earphones
to avoid others and concentrate on her
studies but one day a large commotion
disturbs her everyone is rushing to the
balcony to look at something Chen also
follows them and notices her best friend
who shouty lying on the ground it
appears as if she has committed the
unthinkable many students gather around
her but instead of helping they start
clicking pictures to share on their
social media accounts distraught and
disgusted Shen slowly approaches her
best friend's body and covers it with
her jacket it is then revealed that the
entire School knows the reason why who
committed the unthinkable but they are
too afraid to speak in public the next
day during class Chen is called to the
principal's office where some police
detectives have arrived they question
her about who's death and if they were
good friends surprisingly Chen denies
knowing her and claims that she simply
covered her face as all the other
students were clicking her picture the
detectives find it hard to believe but
nonetheless they let her go when Chen
returns to her classroom she finds red
ink on her chair she then remembers that
her best friend who was also bullied in
similar fashion before her death later
as Chen is in the cafeteria the leader
of the bully group Wei Lei approaches
her and asks her for help in the
upcoming exams Chen replies that she
doesn't have time for that so Wale
starts taking pictures of her just like
she used to of who here it is finally
revealed that the bullies were
responsible for whose death they
regularly tormented her which completely
broke her from the inside Chen is aware
of all this but she is too afraid to
tell the police on her way home weilay
and the other bullies attack her just
because she talked to the police
officers despite all this Chen does not
speak a word and simply goes home where
she finds her mother it turns out the
latter barely comes home because she
sells illegal goods for a living she
doesn't want her daughter's studies to
be affected by her business so she tries
to stay away from her as much as she can
at night before going to bed the mother
promises Chen that soon she will buy a
new house where they can live happily
early the next morning she leaves
without informing her daughter however
Chen finds out about this and becomes
sad in the evening as she is returning
from school she notices a group ganging
up on a boy named Xiao bay chen decides
to call the police but one of the boys
notices her and takes her phone away the
group then takes all her money and
forces her to kiss Xiao after this they
start laughing at her pitiful state but
this only makes Xiao angrier he gets up
and dishes out a brutal punishment on
the leader of the group prompting the
others to run away before leaving shout
stares into Chen's eyes but doesn't say
anything the following day however he
meets her personally and thanks her for
saving him he then inquires how much
money the gang took from her Chen
replies 50 Yuan but Xiao doesn't have
change to pair so he offers to repair
her phone which was damaged in the
altercation from last night at the
repair shop Xiao offers to be Chen's
bodyguard in return for money however
she refuses saying he couldn't even take
care of himself yesterday later Xiao
follows her everywhere she goes outside
her home Chen notices many posters
accusing her mother of not paying her
debts in time enraged she tears every
single one of them down before storming
inside unfortunately at school the
poster has already become viral and all
the students make fun of Chen when she
can't bear it anymore she leaves her
class and returns home this is something
she has never done in her life on her
way Chen runs into Xiao and the two
eventually get to talking she explains
everything that happened in class and in
response Xiao tries to console her he
then takes her to his place which is a
small shabby house located under a
bridge at night the two eat noodles and
have a good time all of a sudden Shao
inquires if she likes him but Shen
rudely tells him that he doesn't have
any qualities that are like worthy this
infuriates Xiao so he shoves her against
the wall and says this is how I am
following this Chen returns home crying
the only person who had started to
understand her has put hands on her
today the following day during gym class
Chen is ignored by everyone no one wants
to play volleyball with her weilay and
her friends use this opportunity to make
fun of her mercilessly they even strike
her with the volleyball multiple times
later Chen is pushed down the stairs but
fortunately she doesn't sustain any
serious injuries fed up with the bullies
Chen decides to tell everything to the
Police Inspector Zhang Yi afterward Wale
and her friends are called by the police
for interrogation all of them blame
who's family's condition and her
character for her death rather than
confessing what they did to her the
police let them go but the school
decides to suspend the bullies for an
entire year the next day inspector Zhang
calls Shannon offers her a ride he
apologizes for not being able able to
punish the bullies and bring Justice to
the deceased who that night as Chen is
about to enter her home the bully group
is waiting for her at the entrance they
are angry that she complained to the
police and got them expelled from school
for Revenge they have brought a box of
mice which they plan to unleash on Chen
fortunately the latter manages to run
away and hide inside a garbage bin after
the bullies are gone she slowly gets out
and goes to the only person who can help
her Shao she tells him everything and
asks if he will protect her even though
she has nothing to offer in return from
the next day onwards Xiao follows Chen
to the school and escorts her back she
even starts living with him in his house
because Xiao is a gang member he often
comes back home beaten and injured one
day when he returns severely injured
Chen asks him if he is all right she
even requests him to come and sleep
beside her Xiao reveals that his father
left him when he was 13 years old and
his mother abandoned him for another man
he further mentions that Chen is the
first person to ask him if his injuries
hurt from that night on words the two
get along very well they enjoy each
other's company and are playful when
together Chen is able to focus better on
her studies when Shaz boss calls him for
a fight she stops him knowing that he
will get beaten up again surprisingly
Xiao obeys and stays home unfortunately
one day Xiao gets arrested for being a
suspect in a robbery case he along with
his friends are taken to the police
station and are arrested until the
culprit is found meanwhile Chen is about
to return from school so she calls Xiao
escort her home when he does not pick up
she reluctantly decides to walk home
alone unfortunately wayley and her bully
group find her alone and start beating
her up they punch her cut her hair and
even strip her clothes they also record
the entire thing to blackmail her later
but before they can injure her seriously
a passerby notices them and threatens to
call the police hearing this the bullies
run away leaving a bruised and
humiliated Shin on the road shortly
after Xiao gets released from the police
station and calls Chan but she does not
answer worried he immediately rushes to
his place and finds Chen wounded and
trying to tape her torn notebooks shall
fumes at the site he grabs a metal rod
ready to kill all the bullies but Shen
stops him later he shaves her hair to
make it even and shaves his own so she
wouldn't feel as bad one night Waley
approaches Chen and apologizes for her
mistakes she even offers her money and
begs her not to tell the police about
her wrongdoings she is scared that she
will have to repeat the great again and
her father who hasn't spoken to her for
a year will get even angrier Chen
forgives her and tells her not to show
her face again but when she tries to
walk away waylay follows her and starts
criticizing her mother this infuriates
Chan so much that she pushes the bully
down the stairs as she watches on waylay
bashes her head on the concrete ground
and dies on the spot terrified Chen
immediately goes to show and tells him
about what happened she now fears that
she will be arrested and given the death
sentence however shall consoles her
promising to get rid of waylay's body he
then visits one of his friends and
borrows his car for the night following
this Xiao takes weilay's body to a
secluded area and buries it with pieces
of evidence that would lead the police
back to him on the other hand Chen is
very anxious so to divert her mind she
focuses on her final examination on the
day of the exam it rains heavily and the
authorities urge the students to leave
early so that they can reach the school
on time landslides also occur in a major
part of the highway while clearing the
landslide a driver discovers waylay's
dead body on further investigation the
police find out about the car shall used
that night they track the owner and
ultimately get the information on Xiao
Wale's friends are also brought to the
police station for interrogation and
they directly blame Chen for her death
meanwhile officer Zhang finds the video
of Chan being humiliated by waylay and
starts suspecting her for the death
hence Chen is taken to the police
station and asked where she was on the
day wayle died Shen replies that she was
busy preparing for her final exams when
asked why she didn't inform the police
officers about being humiliated she
replies that all she wanted was to move
out of the place and study in Beijing
after interrogating her for more than an
hour the police escort her back to her
place but decide to keep a close eye on
her the following day as Chen is
returning home from school Xiao suddenly
approaches her and takes her to the
basement of an abandoned building he
locks the door leaving all the police
officers outside Xiao wants Chen to
blame him for assaulting her so that the
police will assume he did the same to
weilay that way they would let Chen free
and he would be convicted for waylay's
death as expected Shen refuses but when
Xiao explains that he is a minor and
that he will not get a very harsh
sentence she degrees after a while when
the police finally arrived he acts like
he is assaulting her and gets arrested
in the next scene officer Zhang looks at
numerous CCTV footage and discovers that
Xiao had been following Shen for a very
long time on asking why he did so Xiao
replies that he was just stalking her
Chen is also brought in for
interrogation and asked about weilay's
death she denies her involvement and
pretends like she doesn't know about
Xiao Xiao also acts as if he doesn't
know Chen he was merely stalking her
because he found her pretty after taking
in all the statements Shen is released
due to lack of evidence as for Xiao he
is imprisoned several days passed by and
now Chen has started living with her
mother she tries focusing on her studies
but can't because her mind is full of
the memories she spent with Xiao she
misses him very much and often breaks
down in desperation the only good thing
is that she gets good marks in her exams
making her mother proud one evening
officer Zhang visits Chan and
congratulates her on topping the class
however he he also reveals that Xiao has
been given a death sentence due to the
severity of his past crimes perplexed
Chen starts crying and says that it is
impossible because Xiao is a minor but
officer Zhang tells her that it is a lie
Zhao is actually 23 years old hearing
this Chen becomes delirious and starts
attacking the officer to calm her down
officer Zhang finally reveals that he
was just lying about the death sentence
but now that he knows that the two have
a relationship he wants Chen to confess
the truth she is reluctant but the
officer promises to reduce their
sentences if they are honest later Chen
meets Xiao in prison and informs him
that she has confessed everything now
she is being taken to another prison and
her life is going to be destroyed
however the relief she is found by
confessing is priceless following this
the movie flashes back to the present
where Chen has grown up to become an
English teacher she has left her
criminal past behind and now looks to
start a new career when she notices the
silent kid Chen recall calls how she was
tormented during her childhood the movie
ends as Chen escorts the kid all the way
to her home encouraging her to fight
against the bullies behind them is Xiao
who still likes to follow Chan
everywhere she goes you'll notice I
didn't make any jokes in this recap
that's because bullying is no joke it
may sound lame but if you're a part of
that kind of thing even as a group
please realize that you've no idea how
much damage it can do and you have the
power to stop it subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching